here in this video we are going to
discuss about questions that has bugged
our minds ever since they announced that
there would be a sequel to godzilla vs
kong yeah guys there will be another
follow-up movie to this year's mega
monster mashup
the most of us isn't dead it is going to
be continued and its end is still not
yet come godzilla vs kong sequel is
reportedly in early development with
godzilla vs kong's director adam wingard
leading it and could potentially be
titled the son of gong
but there was also another rumor that it
might be a godzilla movie during the
prehistoric ages and yet we have a
feeling that it would be godzilla vs
kong part 2 given the success of this
year's flick
so here let us discuss the reasons why
they will fight again in the next movie
reason number one gaza turns evil due to
the eevee legends and prophecies the
first reason that we can think of is
that if the movie was set up thousands
or millions of years ago during the time
when humans and titans lived in harmony
in the hollow earth it was clearly
explained in the novelization of
godzilla
that he turned evil when he ate a power
source of which the eeries called a star
and became obsessed with power so if
this was to happen we would see a major
titan battle in the hollow earth between
godzilla and the ones who follow him
which might include the other titans
against the tribe of kongs and the
humans that side with them which would
be called the eevees later on
reason number two godzilla comes to the
hollow earth and kong's home
the second reason why godzilla and kong
would fight is that if godzilla
inadvertently enters the hollow earth
and maybe due to reasons like he needs
to repower up using the radiation in
that place or from the power sources
that can be seen in a throne room of
kong
this would stir enmities and since kong
bounced to no one there might be another
major battle between them and this time
it would be beneath the surface of the
world and since godzilla was the one who
caught the destruction of gong's
ancestral home it would be epic to see
vengeance exactly on the big g by the
eighth wonder of the world
reason number three kong defends his son
and other kongs so let's go to the third
reason why they would battle it out
again and this is more closely linked to
the probable movie son of kong we don't
really have any clue as to how kong
would have a son he clearly is a male an
apes gone lay egg so there might be
other kongs in hiding in the hollow
earth or yet another subspace of the
earth's surface that can be inhabited by
these giant apes so there might come a
scenario where gaza finds these kongs
and since he has battled them before he
would do it again to only be stopped by
kong and this would lead to another mega
showdown
reason number four either godzilla or
kong is under mind control in the past
godzilla and other kaijus had been
victims of mind control from human
villains or aliens from other planets
and they have been used to fight the
earth's military if there was ever a
better reason for these two monsters to
fight again
is if one of them was compromised
mentally and under the control of
another evil force imagine kong being
tricked into wearing a mind control
device and then he turns bad and starts
another battle with godzilla but in the
end both of them are killed and the only
one surviving is the son of kong and
maybe monarch finds godzilla junior
later on and then the motras egg that
was found in king of the monsters it
hatches so a next generation of monsters
reason number five rematch and the final
declaration of kong as king finally the
main reason as to why they would fight
again is that the current score is one
is to one in 1962 kong won the battle
and in this year's movie it was clearly
godzilla that defeated kong so whatever
the scenario may be these two kaiju's
the king of the monsters and the eighth
wonder of the world
might have a final showdown to sell once
and for all if japan or the us created a
better creature and yes which one is the
better monster this would also end in
kong probably being crowned as king kong
which he has never been termed as in the
most of us but just teased at from time
to time but yet again godzilla might
kick the crap out of the big cape again
so there's that and so with that we come
to the end of this video of the five
reasons why kong and godzilla might
fight again
we just hope that you know
they might and it's not a standalone
sequel
so
do click that like button for support
and subscribe to be a part of our mind
cue family and also don't forget to hit
that bell button for regular updates on
new master content right here on this
channel till the next one
take care fam